Hausa go back here where we're gonna
play some bein sweet and you never play
this but I have I cheated a little bit
so we can go through the training there
we go all right so you're balling I'm
cute these are bombs and then you start
sorry throw throw throw three if I'm
only too long you two eat alone in your
face whatever that's what she's saying
okay good job no you hold it too long it
or you can questions and if you want to
it's really good yes you can
oh I killed myself for you yeah thank
you yeah I'm dying I die it's all you
it's all you if we have to do it yeah
you have to do it you have to die
yeah it's okay it's a good sir warm-up
rattler or whatever oh I'm gonna show
you now that they get the game okay
whatever whatever I'm gonna be so much
better than II fine a little present for
them right away what what did you do
there's no bombs that follows you don't
panic
what is this fun punch out oh wow that's
me okay all right look at this Oh
what are you doing brawl tipping tipping
guns hey guys I am punching that's me
that's okay
what you can't leave me alone
kill them kill them I am trying okay so
phosphate last way we have to do this oh
[ __ ] they're so dangerous
I hate those girls girls burgers and
they throw like crazy you go near oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
tonight no I did not say that they're
crazy
I hate them aah hey you see his friend
oh thank you to them you latina you look
I'm pirate how pirate evil you're racist
you have a problem what are you doing
okay this is lies run we have to make
this one okay it's the one with the gas
yeah I hate them
god I hate them oh they're so bad why
sometimes I can't so far I know you have
to like it's me oh my god oh no no just
go up let's go up but if you're not
moving enjoying okay okay you punching
this is laying thing oh no he's punching
me oh thank you God all right okay focus
focus we came so far nice nice nice
okay okay yeah don't lose focus
last round now girls there's girls
there's gonna be girls there's gonna be
girl
they're crazy they're seriously out of
oh yeah top what not then I tried
well trying doesn't kill people you
punch that [ __ ] punch that [ __ ] oh we
did it
it's okay okay all right now comes the
real challenge okay all right thank you
thank you for that thank you Joe
punch thank you thank you wait wait wait
oh okay fine fine you're fine you're
fine you're fine
I get the girls oh my me I can't fight
them all really oh yeah you sure Chuck
Chuck
oh my god oh my god yes Oh No go up go
up okay okay you can do pizza oh oh
we're gonna give good really corny why
what what's up what's up
Oh what are you doing there oh okay
punch it punch your mother lying down
no problem you did it holy [ __ ] okay
very are very welcome pants thank yes
yeah yeah the girl what nothing [ __ ]
you're so crazy
be careful okay okay let's go right now
throw bombs everywhere mother ninjas
they're gonna punch it again
don't be but right now it's all on you
it's all on you yeah it's all of you
you're way too good at this game
and those me dying I do all the dirty
work I never play this I never play
football score three touchdowns how did
that edit I don't know how do you get it
don't worry don't worry about oh come on
come on
that is so cheesy okay I get it you
cover me okay
cover me and touchdown yeah oh you get
it I cover you you get it I caught me
why that I'm getting it yeah so he's
gonna freeze he's gonna freeze you froze
night Rosie Oh get the flag get the flag
what are you doing yeah I'll I'll Yolo
with this back off back off back off
dude why don't I tell it to them he says
we're so bad let go man cover me yeah
harder touchdown okay got it
oh that's pretty good actually what are
you doing man
okay fire touchdown hey go Yolo Yolo
Yolo Yolo Yolo yo
yeah goddamnit I don't know how you're
gonna do it yeah run past it no you are
not going anywhere sir okay don't worry
don't worry doll I'm dead no no don't
say that no way no way
don't worry I got ya yeah there you go
thanks again I'll just get the fact that
are not getting this out that is my flag
no that was bomb squad hope you enjoyed
watching Leo like for part two if you
want more hits the sky cover with today
and we'll see you next time
brofist
yeah
ah [ __ ]